and can
see the screen
what we'll do today is we'll
give you an overview of the program
i will pass this on to
sparsh
momentarily but
to give you an introduction
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
is a program designed to introduce you
to the ways that bioinformatics is used
in the study for infectious diseases
coming from different types of pathogens
and what we'll do is we'll introduce you
to
curated
examples
of how you can analyze data where to
find such data and how to make
conclusions
okay so uh what i'll do in my part of
the presentation
is i will review some of the
introductory material about the program
then i will pass it on to uh dr rugger
bendron who is going to review some of
the practical things of how you can get
started with some of the types of data
that is usually used
for uh these kinds of studies
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is a program that is designed
for biologists clinicians students that
are interested in virology microbiology
and immunology
that would like to learn how to apply
bioinformatics to different types of big
data for research and applications about
infectious diseases to design novel
diagnostic approaches
to understand how antiviral and
antimicrobial drugs are being designed
how vaccines are relying on data and
bioinformatics to
address
new and maybe potentially in the future
upcoming disease outbreaks
and also how to understand what are some
of the important challenges and
questions that remain to be answered and
how bioinformatics can help us address
those as well
so what i'll do is i'll first explain
how some of the questions
about infectious diseases are related to
bioinformatics
you know
if we can think about this program as
just a series of questions that one can
ask and use bioinformatics to find
potential answers
one question might be
what is a pathogen
what differentiates pathogens from
non-pathogens what differentiates for
example bacteria that coexist together
with humans plants and other hosts
from those that cause disease
how can that help us
understand the evolution or the
conditions of competition that cause
these
microorganisms to evolve
share recipes
kind of record what works and how to
adapt what they the tools that they have
to overcome different types of
challenges
another question can be
where do diseases come from how come is
it that some diseases persist
and some diseases have these outbreaks
that are acute that have a beginning
that have an end
where do they come from
how do we understand the origins of
diseases like coronavirus or ebola or
other diseases that cause these endemic
or pandemic outbreaks
how can we understand this in the
context of interaction between different
hosts for example different species
humans their pets uh the
different cattle that we grow
how can that be
a source of novel pathogens
what is the actual disease that they
cause right how can we describe
the reaction of the host to the pathogen
as a condition that we can diagnose so
what makes that as a
disease and we can think of all of these
microorganisms as essentially parasites
that
leverage some of the resources that the
hosts have accumulated leverage their
mechanisms of production of vital
proteins to be able to replicate
themselves
and how they as a result
of hijacking some of these resources can
also cause toxicity and disruption of
the host function
we'll also talk about how diseases
spread because what characterizes an
infectious disease or a communicable
disease and sets it apart from other
types of diseases which are commonly
known as chronic diseases like cancer
for example or hypertension
is the fact that they're caused by
pathogen and that pathogen
is a
transmittable pathogen you can actually
share it between individuals and so when
we think of that transmission and the
pattern of transmission we can also use
bioinformatics to understand the
population scale
how does the population react to a
disease
for example herd immunity
or how does the population
become susceptible for example having
similar characteristics within a
particular group or a population how can
that make them more susceptible to
particular types of diseases
and we'll also talk about the balance of
replication and how
while a pathogen causes acute disease
oftentimes
one of its objectives is to continue and
replicate and find a balance where it
can continue to replicate and spread
between many individuals causing them to
potentially have mild condition
that does not prevent it from continuing
to replicate
then we'll talk about how to treat or
prevent disease and we'll talk about how
novel advances
are examples of bioinformatics in part
because
understanding the particular situations
where vaccines can be more adapted to
the specifics of the pathogen
and maybe novel antivirals could be
designed based on our understanding of
the interaction between the host and the
pathogen can lead to
novel ways to treat disease but we'll
also talk about how early diagnostics or
understanding specifically what pathogen
and what strain of a pathogen or maybe a
variant of a pathogen is causing a
disease is critical
for the future of these kinds of
interventions because as we will see in
the last portion what remains to be done
we'll see how
the same principles of evolution can
help us understand how the diseases that
are caused by pathogens
are only
preventable if we can develop systems of
early detection and understanding of the
evolution that they undergo because we
can identify precise variants and we can
treat that precise variant but we don't
always know how to anticipate novel
variants and to anticipate novel
variants and design therapeutics that
can potentially
co-evolve with these pathogens
there are new strategies and novel
understanding about how these types of
discoveries can really help us
anticipate and prevent future outbreaks
so in the context of this particular
online program what we have prepared on
our side are a number of examples or
let's call them case studies
case studies where we can take curated
data sets
and start designing bioinformatics
projects where we have a question we
have a data set and then we have a path
to answer that question from that data
set or methods of analysis of data that
could inform some of our understanding
of the answers to these questions
so what are some of these case studies
and data sets
one of them is going to be about the
ebola outbreak in 2014 to 2016.
now what's
interesting about this outbreak is that
it is one of the first examples
where large-scale
genomic sequencing was employed
almost in real time to track an epidemic
to understand how the epidemic is
spreading in a particular
region
and then use this understanding to
design a vaccine in an antiviral drug
another example that we're going to look
at is going to speak about
the spread of covet 19. and when we
think about cove at 19 we obviously hear
so much about it in the news
but what is exceptionally um
i think
kind of for bioinformaticians is
interesting in this pandemic
specifically is that the amount of data
and the detail of data
is now uh
very rich and and very
precise
being updated almost in real time
from many different regions so really
the scale of the data collection here is
unheard of in any other kind of disease
not only that this particular pandemic
has popularized some of the terms that
we rely on as bioinformaticians to
understand how genomes of particular
pathogens
or how molecular
biology and and kind of the background
of how these pathogens cause disease are
really becoming understood by even the
general public so today everyone
understands what a variant or a mutation
is everyone appreciates the ability to
study some genomic pattern and try to
make inference that has a practical
application we don't have to explain
the need to
understand and maybe
sequence some of these pathogens because
now everyone is
in tune with this scientific endeavor to
try to really understand how this
pathogen is evolving right we don't need
to
explain that it is evolving right
everybody knows that so really we're
going to take a look at some of those
data sets in this as well
another example that we will look at is
the development of vaccines to address
the
kind of chronic
or endemic
plasmodium falciparum
spread in africa and in south asia
we'll take a look at how
genomic surveillance and understanding
of both
resistance to some of the known drugs
that are used to treat plasmodium as
well as the efforts to design an
effective vaccine
that turns out to be a non-trivial
effort that requires a deep
understanding of genomic variability
across different regions and the
understanding of how that genomic
variability can be
used or leveraged to really find an
effective way to interfere
we'll also look at
how uh viruses are not only um the
result of
these kinds of acute outbreaks of
infectious diseases but we'll also see
how there's a greater appreciation of
the role that viruses play in other
types of diseases for example in
neurodegenerative diseases like multiple
sclerosis
where
maybe
an exciting idea resulting from this
observation is that if we treat the
virus if we find a way to treat the
virus the viral infection we don't have
to deal with the symptoms with the
consequences that are the outcome of
this persistent infection leading to
these long-term deterioration of
the cognitive function
we'll also take a look at how these
types of observations are relevant in
diseases like cancer
where abstain virus and others have uh
been found to play a major role in the
onset and maybe uh development of these
cancers so i think really
infectious diseases
now is going from some of these uh
prominent case studies that we're going
to take a look at like ebola malaria and
kovid and even extend to some of the
non-typically considered as infectious
diseases but
chronic diseases that potentially have a
connection to
viral pathogens and others
we'll also look at some of the
challenges that still remain to be
addressed
even though
we think of treatments like antibiotics
for example
as an established way to treat disease
that have been very successful over the
past several decades
these kinds of interventions are new
our ability to design vaccines and adapt
them to particular pathogens is
something that happened in the past
maybe decade our ability to
leverage the antibiotics to treat these
bacterial diseases is also just a few
decades old
and as a result of widespread use of
these uh types of interventions we're
also seeing the reverse reaction right
where we are seeing how these types of
interventions can become weaker over
time
as a result of evolution and adaptation
we see emergence of
resistance and drug resistant
tuberculosis for example is a major risk
we can see a novel pathogens bacterial
pathogens that are emerging in hospitals
that are not
possible to treat with antibiotics we're
also seeing novel variants of these
viral diseases that also do not respond
well to vaccines that were designed so
really these are some of the challenges
that continue to
emerge
in these kinds of effective ways to
leverage bioinformatics and we'll talk
about where we can find some data sets
and what are some of the methods of
analysis that we can leverage to try and
answer some of these questions and
challenges
now where can you find some of these
we have designed a portal where our team
has curated project examples
and
tutorials that you can leverage
as an independent learner as someone who
just wants to obtain some bioinformatics
skills or as someone that would like to
apply some of the bioinformatics skills
to a particular research question
and so those are some of the things that
you will find on the portal and i will
explain today how you can leverage this
portal more effectively in the context
of this online training portal that is
going to provide you with live sessions
as well as some of these online
resources that you can leverage to
really master some of these skills and
practice them on particular examples
so to talk about this i'll speak about
where you can find a particular resource
that you might be interested in how you
can find different categories or even
collections of different courses and
we'll see how to get started
now beyond this i want to mention that
what you will hear in this program is
going to be based on tutorials that were
prepared in collaboration with a number
of experts in this domain so really what
we did is we worked with the number of
researchers that are actively
investigating
um all of these topics from the
perspective of pure bioinformatics or an
algorithmic perspective how to design
methods to analyze such data effectively
we've worked with researchers that
specialize in some of these pathogens
and have been performing research in the
area of malaria or coronaviruses for a
long time and also people that apply the
bioinformatics to connect the biological
questions with the specific data sets
that are available and are being
extended and
populated with these new
viral and bacterial genomes or even
parasite genomes in the case of malaria
to try and answer these questions
comprehensively so we'll
leverage their expertise and we'll
present to you some of the findings and
questions and solutions that they have
identified
so what is this program all about this
program bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is going to help you understand
pathogens and the diseases that they
cause
where they come from
what are the processes that cause
the different types of changes in their
genomes that we can observe
how can they cause infection and how can
that infection cause disease
we'll also talk about the specific ways
to analyze such data a lot of this data
is going to be focused on the
understanding of genomic variability and
how to identify specific genomic
variants and characterize them in terms
of their impact on the pathogen itself
on the interaction between the pathogen
and the host and potentially on the
intervention in that interaction
we'll also talk about how you can apply
some of these principles to study a
variety of different curated data sets
identify the questions that are
important for these data sets and then
use the data sets and the methods that
we described to find answers to these
important questions and again you will
have access to some resources that will
make your life easier if you're just
getting started but also for those of
you that are already more advanced we
will help you connect the dots and
really apply these methods in an
effective way
now the program is going to help you by
leveraging two
primary resources that i want to
introduce briefly before we begin
the first of
them is going to be our big data
analysis platform some of these data
sets are going to be exceptionally large
we're going to leverage hundreds if not
thousands of genomes at a specific time
we're going to look at complex data like
rna sequencing even single cell rna
sequencing and so to facilitate some of
the educational aspects of our
interaction we're going to rely on this
platform that i'm going to demonstrate
in just a few moments
the other part is of course our omics
logic portal that i already briefly
mentioned but i want to highlight the
significance of this online resource
because it provides a collection of
elements that are going to be useful as
you
start in this particular program and
continue after that so that you can
understand the high level overview in a
short program like we have today but
then continue by leveraging some of the
specific technical tutorials to really
expand and practice and master these
skills so that you are independent and
confident in the way that you apply them
so before we begin what i would like
everyone to do is to log in to this
portal so let's go to learn
dot
this is a portal where you can register
for free so anyone even if you're not
going to participate in this particular
program you can register
and i'll i'm putting this link here so
that all of you who have not registered
as of now can take a moment to register
now i'm going to demonstrate and please
follow along if you have not registered
already
so i'm going to log out the first thing
that you will see right here in the menu
is this login screen
okay so if you press on the login
you can either log in with your email
and password
you can create an account again this is
a free account
you put in your name email and think of
a password
or you can also use different types of
social media plugins so after you have
created that
i'm just going to use my own password to
log in
and the first thing that you will see if
you are registering for the first time
is actually the pricing page but if you
go from the pricing page
you should see right here on the very
top
your email address and so that's what we
want to do is we want to click on this
email address right here
so this email address is your
profile
okay so please let me know once you have
your profile in front of you i'm going
to walk you through some of the things
that you're going to be seeing so just
let me know in the chat by saying yes
putting number one or something in the
chat so that i know that you're with me
on your profile
[Music]
all right excellent thank you brian
helene
again i'm going to give another 30
seconds for those of you that are still
creating your profile please let me know
once you're done
all right thank you priyanka sarah
excellent okay
anna
all right
so
this profile is really designed to kind
of connect all of the different
resources
naveen
the creation of the profile itself is
free so really there's no shouldn't be
any worry about cost right now right the
profile is free you'll have access to a
lot of free resources if you have
questions about pricing uh later on uh
please reach out to our marketing team
but right now i'm just showing you a
free resource that you can already
leverage from day one so in this profile
you'll see how the different resources
are connected
to your learning journey
and we're
kind of emphasizing this section because
really this is where you can track your
progress you can go back to where you
were to pick up where you started you
can always find your certification here
etc so all of this material is going to
be here
what is the expectation of this
particular program
this particular program will help you
identify the specific topics that you
need to master
try to apply them to different projects
and then use the annotation of our
tracking of your progress to earn a
certificate and so this certificate is
going to be the validation of your
kind of understanding of bioinformatics
in infectious diseases number one
but number two it will also provide you
with an opportunity to develop an
independent research
project so one of our
primary objectives in these kinds of
training programs is to support
research that is coming
from a bioinformatics perspective
how to apply bioinformatics to research
that is what we're really going to
address in this training program now
this training program will have a
dedicated program page
on that page you will find all of the
sessions that will be recorded
you will also find a schedule of how to
uh go to the right kind of a topic at
the right time
and
how to connect to the live sessions that
we have
today
now beyond that you will also find all
of the resources now we understand that
many of you are coming from different
backgrounds you might be already an
expert in bioinformatics and you would
like to understand how specifically
bioinformatics applies to infectious
diseases or you might be a complete
novice and you really don't know a lot
of the topics that we are discussing
maybe you're not familiar with the
terminology for example so that's why we
include in this particular program also
the introductory coursework like bytes
and molecules introduction to
bioinformatics and others where you can
start with the very basics and develop
your
kind of understanding of the different
terms that you will find useful as we go
through the different case studies
as i mentioned we will have some live
sessions like today but we will also
have recorded sessions and so you will
find those in the schedule and you will
finally be able to interact with our
community by asking them questions
about the specific topics that we are
discussing and getting maybe technical
answers to overcome your challenges so
if you ever get stuck and if you ever
have maybe a frustration like always
happens in these online courses i don't
understand i i can't do what you know
i'm being told to do you can always
reach out to us so our team is going to
be there to support your journey
and you're going to be able to
then go through uh the specific
tutorials that we recommend to learn
about them
now if you don't see any courses that is
because you are likely just signing up
so if you go to this page the course tab
has the courses that you've already
started okay if you want to find a
course you have to go to the top menu
and this is our library of resources and
find the relevant course for example if
i would like to learn about covid
i will find stars go to genomics
as an introductory project right here so
once you start this and you start by
clicking on the lesson
and now you've started this project you
can learn through and then click on next
and eventually that will appear on your
profile as well so christine hopefully
that answers your question right there
okay so
finally before we go on i want to
recommend
you to connect to our community as well
so what this program represents is a
community effort not only are we going
to have these kinds of sessions and
interact with you try to help you try to
explain some of these topics in an
accessible approachable way and really
distill these complex topics to some
simple exercises that anyone can perform
we're also there to connect a community
of learners to opportunities and those
opportunities might be professional
opportunities to develop your career in
bioinformatics also opportunities to
connect with potential research
collaborators so we're going to
introduce you to some of those groups
and today i'm just going to share here
in the chat two of our groups that you
can connect to one of them is on
linkedin and another one is on facebook
for those of you that are on either one
of those platforms we welcome you to
connect with us personally but also to
connect with the broader community that
we serve we have over i think 1500
people on linkedin over 10 000 people on
facebook so
you can really
leverage this community to not only
learn about bioinformatics for
infectious diseases but then also to
continue and apply bioinformatics to
other domains and to advance your career
or find opportunities for research
so today's session
is going to be dedicated to next
generation sequencing
one of the technologies that has really
advanced our understanding and ability
to treat and diagnose diseases like
infectious diseases is our ability to
sequence genomes and transcriptones and
understand what's going on at the
molecular level
so when we think about next generation
sequencing and the way it has become
popular and maybe widely used as a
technique
this has happened in the course of the
past couple of decades and today with
decreasing cost of sequencing it is
being used in remote
areas where some of these diseases are
originating where some of these diseases
are being changed and transformed but
also in most
kind of technologically advanced places
it is becoming a more and more reliable
and
useful technology to understand
infectious diseases so to learn more
about this technique i am going to
invite dr raghav to speak about how next
generation sequencing works
what it contains what kind of
information it contains and how you can
potentially start learning to use it to
actually apply it
in the context of infectious diseases
so raga
yeah hello everybody let me find ways to
share my screen